وصلت رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه ارسولا
فوندر لاين زياره تود بعث رساله سياسيه
مفادها انا الاتحاد الاوروبي يقف الى صفي
اوكرانيا في نزاعها العسكري امام روسيا
وان ابواب الاتحاد مفتوحه امام اوكرانيا
للحصول على عضويته
والحكومه الاوكرانيه بشكل اساسي على طريقه
العمل نفسها
فقط على دعم الشعب الاوكراني ولكن ايضا
على كيفيه بناء مستقبل اوكرانيا في
الاتحاد
الاوروبيون الزياره تقلل بقمه اوروبيه
اوكرانيه بحضور فوندر لاين وشارل ميشيل
رئيس المجلس الاوروبي وهي القيمه الاولى
منذ بدء الحرب يريد منها الاتحاد التاكيد
على دوره المحوري في الدعم الاقتصادي
والسياسي والعسكري للكلاب في ظل الحرب
مسؤول خارجيه الاتحاد اكد على دعم الجيش
الاوكراني يسعدني ان اعلن لرئيس الوزراء
الاوكراني ان بعثه المساعده العسكريه
للاتحاد الاوروبي ستدرب 15 الف جنديا
اوكرانيا اضافي دول الاتحاد تستقبل 4
ملايين ونصف مليون لاجئ اوكراني وبلغ حجم
الانفاق الاوروبي في المساعدات الانسانيه
والماليه والعسكريه 49 مليار يورو